[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we're going to examine the
differences between two sister languages
Indonesian also known as bahasa
indonesia and malaysia known as bahasa
melayu Slama natandy indonesia welcome
in indonesia
selamat datang to malaysia welcome to
Malaysia as you can see at first glance
the two languages seem essentially the
same and their standard varieties are in
large part mutually intelligible but you
can also see that they're not exactly
the same if you've seen my individual
videos on Indonesian and Malay then you
know how this came about but to briefly
recap before the present day countries
of Indonesia Malaysia Brunei and
Singapore existed Malay was spoken
throughout the area and had been a
lingua franca for centuries but in 1928
the Indonesian nationalist movement that
wanted to gain independence from the
Dutch chose Malay as the national
language of their future country and
renamed it to Indonesian or Bahasa
Indonesia while Malaysia Brunei and
Singapore retained the name Malay while
the standard form of Indonesian and the
standard form of Malay are both based on
the same johor dial Malay they have
incorporated different influences in
since 1928 they have moved in different
directions to a certain extent it seems
to me that because it was renamed bahasa
indonesia the Indonesian variety was set
apart from the standard Malay used in
other countries and given a new identity
which allowed it to diverge more freely
today while standard Indonesian and
standard Malay are still nearly
identical in terms of grammar there are
significant differences in vocabulary
I've seen casual estimates that in terms
of vocabulary they are 90% the same and
10% different and that seems reasonable
to me there are also some differences in
pronunciation and spelling Malay used to
only be written in a modified Arabic
script called Joey but it began to be
written with Roman characters during the
colonial period originally the system of
Roman izing Malay in Malaysia Brunei and
Singapore was influenced by
since they were formerly under British
control while in Indonesia
it was influenced by Dutch since
Indonesia was formerly under Dutch
control for example the word for
grandchild choo-choo
was spelled like this in Malaysia and
like this in Indonesia but in 1972 there
was a spelling reform that eliminated
most differences like that but different
influences of English on Malay and Dutch
on Indonesian remain mainly in the
presence of loanwords
sometimes a Dutch loan word is used in
Indonesian when an older Malay word is
used in Malay for example the word for
office in Indonesian it's contoured in
Malay it's bye-bye in Indonesian pyjama
means unofficial rather than an office
the word for room in Indonesian Kumada
in Malay it's Billy Billy is still used
in Indonesian but means a small room
like a booth or compartment related to
that is the word for toilet or restroom
in Indonesian the most common word is
probably Gama ocotilla which literally
means small room in malay the most
common words R and s and Malay ie
which is sort of a lone translation of
water closet or WC sometimes an english
loanword is used in malay while an older
malay word is used in indonesian the
word for hospital in indonesian it's ro
Misaki which literally means sick house
and while both of the words are Malay
this phrase is a lone translation of
Dutch chicken hosh in Malay they simply
say hospital room a socket used to be
used in Malay but it's hardly used
anymore except maybe in some regional
dialects oftentimes
a Dutch loan word is used in Indonesian
while an english loanword is used in
malay these words are often cognates but
have different spelling and
pronunciation for example the word for
television in Indonesian it's lf-cc
while in Malay it's television the word
for police in Indonesian it's policy
while in Malay it's police in Indonesian
police means policy as in an insurance
policy the word for university
universitas university but
sometimes they're not cognates the word
for bag in indonesian us which comes
from dutch and in malay bay the word for
petrol or gasoline benzene at drug the
word for pharmacy meaning the place
where medicines are sold a party
pharmacy in indonesian the word pharmacy
is used to refer to the pharmaceutical
profession and industry but not to shops
there were some different colonial
influences as well for example the word
for towel in Indonesian Honolulu from
Dutch Han Duke in Malay it's Dwolla
which comes from the portuguese word
Talya
there are numerous words from portuguese
in both malay and indonesian because
malacca in present-day malaysia was a
Portuguese colony for over a hundred
years
another example is the word seppuku
meaning shoe which comes from Portuguese
Zapata is the usual word for shoe and
Indonesian but in Malay it's not used
much anymore in the word Casa is used
instead especially by young people
putting aside colonial vocabulary in
particular and looking at vocabulary in
general it's fair to say that the words
that are different in Indonesian and
Malay are often very basic and common
words the word for tree poem vocal the
word for car mobile this is another word
from Dutch and is short for automobile
in Malay it's great in indonesian kurata
means train in this short for pirata a P
and that's the same as the Malay word
for train great therapy caretta a P
literally means fire wagon with wagon
being the original sense of kureta
before it meant car
notice the Malay pronunciation of
caretta caretta final aa is usually
pronounced as a schwa in Malay at least
in Malaysia a couple more examples SIA
meaning I is pronounced SIA and teritama
meaning first is pronounced but a Tama
City kurta Banda in Malay the word Kota
is also used with the meaning of city
but it's used more like that in writing
and the words often used with the sense
of a fort in indonesian banda is usually
a port or a
water channel rather than a city notice
that the final are is silent in many
Malay accents including the mainstream
johor Rio Selangor Malay this is also
the case in some Indonesian accents but
more so among Malay accent bicycle
Cepeda from Lillo seabed the popular
name of early bicycle like vehicles
during the colonial period in Malay it's
bicycle and related to those words are
the words for motorcycle Cepeda motor
motorcycle some terms of address and
family vocabulary are different in
Indonesian Baba or pal are used to
respectfully address a man like sir in
Malay it's 2 n - 1 is also used in
Indonesian but it's very formal
similarly in Indonesian EMU or boo are
used to mean ma'am in Malay the word is
buoy this word does exist in Indonesia
but is a formal literary word and is not
commonly used but pop literally means
father and eboo literally means mother
and with those meanings they are used in
Malay in Indonesian grandfather is
cockle while in Malay it's usually that
dope in Malay caca means older sister
but in Indonesian Papa means older
sibling older brother is lucky lucky and
older sister is Karim well not only
nouns but some verbs are different the
verb meaning can or be able to in
Indonesian it's visa in Malay it's bully
bully is used in Indonesian with the
meaning of may as in you have permission
to do something but in Malay Bolle is
used with both meanings visa comes from
Javanese the most widely spoken native
language in Indonesia a significant
number of Javanese words have entered
Indonesian but not Malay I should note
that there's a different word visa in
both Malay and Indonesian that means
poison or venom the verb meaning to
return come Bali Bali
kamalii is also used but more in writing
in many cases both words exist as
synonyms in either language but there's
a difference in frequency of word choice
take a look at this sentence here this
means I want to eat something
in Indonesian it's samo mackenson
swatter in malay it's sayin at McCann
says what to the verb meaning to want is
different in Indonesian Mao is probably
the most common word in Malay Honda is
more common and in casual speech it's
often abbreviated to na Honda is also
used in Indonesian but less often and mo
is also used in Malay but less
frequently another sentence this means I
always wake up after 9 o'clock in
Indonesian saseru balanced laughs Jamila
in Malay scientist evangeline syllabus
gem symbol a word for word both
sentences are I always wake up after our
9 in Malay send si is often used for
always those Salah Lou is also common in
casual speech in Indonesian Salah Lu is
the most common word Cynthia is rare but
it's longer form sin auntie aza is used
in more formal situations and the most
common word for after in this context in
Indonesian is satella and in Malay
syllabus some words here and there are
spelled a little differently one of the
words meaning to want in Indonesian is
Mao as we saw before in Malay it's mahu
Mao the word for different in Indonesian
is big
while in Malay it's busy the word for
try in Indonesian is soba while in Malay
it's Juba the word for healthy is sad in
Indonesian while it's tsehai in Malay so
far I've mainly been focusing on
standard Indonesian and standard Malay
which are in large part the same except
for some differences in vocabulary and
vocabulary usage but in casual speech
the differences can be much greater
there are numerous regional and local
dialects of Malay and even though
Indonesian has learned as a second
language by most Indonesians it has
developed various local varieties
influenced by regional languages of
Indonesia me and her went to the shop to
buy some food then we ate together first
let's compare the standard sentences in
standard Indonesian oh god Andy Aparna
Kotoko in Doha me I'm a fan on communion
commerce and the salmon and now in
standard Malay I could Andy epic geek
okay down to mommy
mechana command en commun mccann bersama
word for word both sentences are I and
she go to store for buy food then we eat
together
so you can see that these sentences are
almost identical there's just one main
difference the most common words for
store or shop are different in Malay and
Indonesian in Indonesian it's taco while
in Malay it's kadai in Indonesian kadai
is sometimes used but for a small simple
shop like a food stand or kiosk in Malay
kadai is used more generally for most
shops but let's take a look at how this
might be said in casual speech first in
the casual Indonesian of Jakarta who am
at the edge identically movin on throws
ki tamaki madam the first word GUI is a
pronoun originally from hokey and
Chinese that entered casual Jakarta
speech through batali which is spoken by
the original Batali inhabitants of
Jakarta the next word Amma is a
shortened version of sama which means
same or together but here it means and
jalan means walk rather than go this is
simply a matter of word choice the word
buit is used instead of untuk which
means for or for the purpose of in
standard Indonesian and Malay Bua means
do or make but in the casual speech of
Jakarta it also means for or for the
purpose of next the verb Bali meaning to
buy is used in its root form with no
affixes next the word truce is used to
mean then this is a standard word but is
used more in colloquial speech while in
more standard speech communion might be
used next we see the pronoun kita in the
standard sentence the pronoun kami is
used which means we excluding the
listener there is also the pronoun kita
which means we including the listener in
casual Jakarta speech the distinction
between kami and kita is usually ignored
and kita is used unless there's a reason
to emphasize that the listener is
excluded in which case commie can be
used button means with or together with
and this word comes from Javanese now
let's look at a similar sentence but in
the dialect of Johor do Selangor where
kuala lumpur is located a [ __ ] and Iggy
Kadena McCann
skee master ki tarah mackensen sama none
is a short form of the gun which means
with but here it means and deal would be
dia in standard speech ghee is a short
form of the verb turkey which means go
next we see not which means want but
here it's used to mean with the
intention of next again we see Billy
with no affixes and here skeet is a
shortened form of Siddiqui which means a
little but here it doesn't really mean a
little in terms of amount it's just used
to have a softening effect on the
sentence pasta means then and is a
shortened form of celibacy - meaning
after that kita rang comes from kita
plus Oh dong in the casual Malay of
Kuala Lumpur and its surrounding regions
keepo dong is the casual pronoun meaning
kami which means we excluding the
listener sama-sama equals sama-sama or
sama but without the prefix butter again
notice the final schwa vowel on dia and
sama-sama one more sentence I invited
him to play football with us first the
standard sentences in standard
Indonesian
and in standard Malay Sam and jump no
doberman voila c'est par again kami
word-for-word it's I invite him for play
football with us in their standard forms
these sentences are quite similar but we
can see a couple of differences in
Indonesian a common verb meaning invite
is marooned on while in Malay it's man
jump in Indonesian man jump means to
pick up like to pick someone up at the
airport second is the term for football
in Indonesian it's Spock bola which
literally means kick ball in in Malay
it's bolus pot which literally means
ball kick now let's check out the casual
forms of this sentence when an diabolo
Nikita notice here that the word mamoon
dong is shortened to London in casual
speech the suffix moon is often
shortened to here again we see buit in
place of the standard word in tow
meaning for or to notice that the verb
mine appears in its root form without
the prefix that it has in standard
speech next
Paulo is simply bula Amma comes from
summer as we saw before and again kita
rather than kami accordion I mean well
on Katara notice there's a different
verb adjective ight which is also used
in Indonesian when Jim put is more
formal than a jack a jack is used in its
root form note that not seems to be used
in place of unto just like Bua in
Indonesian and just like in casual
Indonesian we see mine in its root form
with no prefix again we see none the
shortened form of the gun and again we
see Quito dong instead of the standard
word kami
as you can see Malay and Indonesian are
very similar languages especially in
their standard forms which are used in
formal and polite situations they're
arguably two standard varieties of the
same language Malay rather than two
separate languages they only really
become undeniably different when we look
at their casual forms which differ from
region to region but it's worth pointing
out that these casual forms don't only
differ between countries they differ
within each country as well so that begs
the question is there really a
distinction between casual Malay and
casual Indonesian or is there simply a
distinction between all of the different
regional dialects regardless of whether
they're male or Indonesian it seems to
me that speakers of both Malay and
Indonesian learn to understand other
casual varieties through exposure and
through exposure to casual varieties of
the other language they would probably
learn to understand them as well as
casual varieties of their own language
so I think it makes sense to consider
Malay and Indonesian
a single plura centric language with
basically two standard varieties and a
variety of different dialects but that's
just my humble opinion what do you think
the question of the day for speakers of
either language Malay or Indonesian do
you consider standard Malay and standard
Indonesian to be varieties of the same
language how about their casual forms
and for other people what's your
impression of Malay and Indonesian do
they seem like different languages to
you if you enjoyed this video check out
the different length okis social media
accounts like Facebook YouTube Twitter
and Instagram and as always I'd like to
say a special thanks to
of my patreon supporters for their
generous monthly pledges especially
these wonderful people right here on the
screen my top tier patreon supporters
many special thanks to them and to
everyone thank you for watching and have
a nice stay
[Music]
[Music]